good job
I must really be out here just shaking
the table and now Amanda seals is
shaking her head after being left out of
the real spare wheel episode there was
never a show that looked like us right
and I'm so grateful and I hope that we
are not the last the comedian who served
as co-host on the daytime show back in
2020 called out the talker on Instagram
after they left her out of the series
finale tribute she kept the caption
simple writing just rude
so apparently the real in their finale
episode did promo
I am not featured in this thumbnail and
I am not featured in the uh farewell
episode apparently
I'll have some things to say about that
oh and the Amanda Army came out in full
force
40 Pals Holly Robinson Pete who was let
go from the talk after one season
responded writing I know the feeling
then there's Amber Riley simply saying I
love you with a laughing emoji Tammy
Roman who appeared as a guest host
during the reels final season argued
that it could have been a decision left
to producers to leave her out of the
finale package but she still thought it
was in very poor taste and the actress
Yvette Nicole Brown echoed the same
sentiment commenting everyone who
contributed to the success of the show
should be celebrated I was talking to my
mom earlier this morning she knows that
you know this is the farewell show and
she was just telling telling me like
you guys really did break the molds of
daytime television and it's so crazy
when you think of it that way Amanda who
is known for her opinionated takes
online did not hold back on Twitter she
responded to a user who asked whether
her contribution was appreciated Amanda
clap back saying sure didn't and the
show could go duck themselves with a
chainsaw for doing so please welcome
[Applause]
foreign
s will recall Amanda quit the Reel just
six months after joining at the time she
explained why the hosting gig wasn't the
right fit does it feel good to my soul
to be at a place where I cannot speak to
my people the way they need to be spoken
to I'm not in a space where I can as a
full black woman have my voice and my
co-workers also have their voices and
where the people at the top are not
respecting the necessity for black
voices to be at the top too but months
before her exit co-host Adrian bilon had
nothing but great things to say about
having Amanda on board I've actually
known Amanda the longest out of anybody
else out of anyone on the panel I've
always loved who she is I've Loved how
opinionated she is and that's what we
really what we love on the show is
having women that have strong opinions
and bring a different perspective and
while we don't know if Amanda faults her
old co-host for being excluded from the
last show she was very vocal when
leaving the Reel that the ladies had
nothing to do with her exit shout out to
Jeannie shout out to Tams shout out to
Lonnie lines and shout out to Adrian
what y'all to understand is grown men
grown women do grown women business
that's what y'all don't understand and
what I do with my business ain't got
nothing to do with them sisters
[Music]